I am a big fan of Daredevil and Charlie
Cox and all those people and I believe
you're part of the upcoming Daredevil
series
um was it talk a little bit about
getting to join the MCU and well can you
tease anything about your role I mean
it's incredible it's so so exciting and
daunting and um everyone is so nice and
so talented and um I remember
getting my first text from the producer
I was driving and I said welcome to the
MCU and like you see that and it's like
it just like hits you you know like and
like I teared up and it's just like oh
my God like it's it's I'm very grateful
and lucky
um
I believe all I can say about my
character
is that I'm from my characters from
Staten Island
and like that's about it
yeah
Staten Island
you know and and yeah yeah
um but I think people are gonna really
be excited to to be in Hell's Kitchen
and and see sort of
um this this the version of Daredevil
that everyone knows and loves but now a
part of this much bigger world where all
of these other players are now sort of
in play so it's it's exciting